un de ceux qui restent ne perd rien dans
un ancien de tepic de l'ancienne
allemagne de l'est
bienvenue losc alors 40 à 60 euros
sous le regard d'un ancien dirigeant
communiste on peut s'offrir un retour en
arrière d'une vingtaine d'années dans la
république démocratique d'allemagne à la
réception des pendules vous donnent
leurs à pékin ou chez le grand frère
soviétique
le téléphone est en ligne avec la police
du peuple et la télé vous emmène dans la
havane d'un fidel castro à l'apogée est
venu pour voir et m'ont fait pas
d'ascenseur pour accéder aux 33 chambres
aménagées dans des appartements d'époque
honecker à laisse tomber radio
authentique tout comme la du rôle des
matelas il ne manque au litre de la
stasi la police secrète de la rda
migrants vol meubles et papiers peints
ont été rachetés chez des antiquaires ou
récupérés dans des familles de l'est
avec un souci du détail jusque dans les
yeux pèse personne ne passait pas une
semaine où les pour une nuit c'est tout
à fait acceptable le patron lui même
issu d'une famille de cirque de la rda
trouve l'allemagne d'aujourd'hui injuste
avec son passé communiste apaisant et
agréable
j'ai eu une enfance eux
revioo et pour attiser le souvenir il y
à même à 15 euros le lit le dortoir des
jeunesses communistes